all right hopefully you are here to hear
about simulation in Python using the
package Senpai
um they told me to be as loud as
possible which is not a problem that I
have so hopefully you can hear me and if
not
um you know make a wave or something and
I will try to do better
the materials for today so this deck
that we're looking at right now you can
find it at the first URL and then I put
up the python notebook both on GitHub
and it's available on Google collab and
I've already run it so if you wanna look
at it right now
um play along feel free to do that and
of course it will be available Forever
After on the internet for your reference
all right what is a simulation so if you
read my little description my little
blurb for this talk hopefully you knew
that you didn't don't need to know
anything about simulation to show up
because I promise to Define it for you
and now we've come to that time where I
will tell you what a simulation is
simulation is a way to solve a decision
problem that we can't easily solve some
other way that's super helpful and what
I mean by that is maybe we can't collect
enough historical data we can't solve a
closed form solution in order to make a
decision about actions that we should
take in our system
and so what we might do if we can't
collect all of that data is to use a
simulation to emulate that behavior so
it's sort of like faking information uh
using computers and the power of
probability and the magic of mathematics
we were able to then build a model of
the system that we're interested in and
be able to see how it behaves maybe when
we change some inputs when we change
constraints and that will give us some
information in order to make any
decision that we might be interested in
if it's based on the performance of a
complex system
and then I say here my last bullet point
from the outputs of the simulation we
can draw inferences that is make
conclusions about the actions that we
should take
there are many types of simulation so
that's very broad
um and also these three types are very
broad categorizations but at a high
level
we have discrete simulations and that
means those simulation is going to be
something that happens over time right
because complex systems they exist in
time something's going to happen and
something's going to happen after it
in discrete time simulations we say that
that time happens discreetly you know uh
I don't want to over explain it at the
risk of over explaining and using the
word discrete a couple of times to
Define discrete by discreet simulations
it can happen in Deltas of time that are
broken down and it's always the same
Delta of time and that's when our state
changes what is the state state is
anything about our simulation anything
about our system any variables that
describe our state or our system
continuous simulation or when we when we
use models of equations where timing is
a little bit less precise
it's often used in ecology
apparently don't ask me about examples
there that's what it said on the
internet I'm not familiar with ecology
but I am familiar with economics and so
it is used there
and then we can add Monte Carlo to our
simulations and Monte Carlo is
more probability on top of probability
and Monte Carlo basically just is about
taking randomly generating what-if
scenarios drawing from distributions and
seeing how that affects our output so a
Monte Carlo simulation would be taking
one of our other simulations and
basically supercharging it by adding
more probability on top of our system
and using probability to change our
inputs and see what happens to our
outputs
today there I can only talk so fast I
can talk faster than this but for your
sake this is as fast as I'm gonna talk
and so we'll only get to talk about
discrete simulation
specifically we're going to talk about
something called discrete event
simulation Des
assumes that our events happen at
specified intervals that means that our
system the variables that describe our
system don't get to change in between
time events happening so our variables
change at those set intervals and
discrete event simulation the event is
An Occurrence that could change the
state of a system so basically
I'm going to get into this a little bit
more detail but we have entities that
are existing in our system they're going
through these discrete bits of time so
from like time T to time t plus one t
plus two and the state of our system can
only change at those discrete points in
time so it has very high level and
you're like can you make this more
concrete
um yes eventually I'm getting there but
uh that is just great event simulation
at a high level
and generally with this great event
simulation we use what's called a next
event Time advance yeah there's a lot of
jargon here so if you don't like
remember it all in the beginning you can
always refer back to it but next event
Time advance means that our variables
our state variables again remember State
variables is just like
what is happening in our systems those
are the variables that explain our
system are going to be updated at
discrete points in time and the clock is
always moving one by one by one
six increment Time advance would be when
that simulation clock so this whole
thing is about simulating a system
there's a clock that's sticking in the
corner right tick tock tick tock in the
corner that is our simulation moving
along and fixed increment Time advance
would be when we move the simulation
clock on those fixed intervals
all right
within discrete event simulation so now
we're going from like the more General
to the more specific we started with
simulation there are many you know three
types we talked about within discrete
simulation we talked about discrete
event simulation
within this great event simulation I'm
specifically going to show you an
example of cueing theory so other things
you can do in discrete event simulation
we're specifically going to talk about
cueing Siri
queuing theory is a branch of operations
research where we use queuing Theory to
make decisions about the number of
resources we need in order to provide a
service
okay so we're going to simulate some
sort of complex system where we have
entities that are resources that are
using some sort of service or server and
we're going to try to find out how many
of them we need so like canonical
example might be bank tellers how many
bank tellers do I need depending on the
amount of customers I have coming
through my branch
um if you are of Generation Z I don't
know if you're familiar there used to be
these buildings where you would go and
you would um interact with people in
person to transact money but
the uh queuing theory was originated by
I'm going to not do a good service of
saying his name but agner karap erlang
um he did this in the 1950s he created
models to describe the system of the
Copenhagen telephone exchange company
I got that from Wikipedia last night I
always like try to add a little bit of
historical interest but basically
queuing Theory here as demonstrated or
illustrated by the schematic we have
some sort of entities customers coming
in through our system they're arriving
to a queuing node within the queuing
node we have different servers and so
they may get service at one of those and
then they're going to depart our system
and that is cueing theory
a little bit more
um technical flourish here so within
queuing Theory we can write it in what's
called candle notation that was defined
in 1953 originally with just three
factors describing so this is a way to
describe a queuing system
okay called candle notation specific to
queuing systems and you would Define it
using the letters a s and C
it tells you the time between arrivals
to the queue so that's the thing in the
middle that queuing node how often are
customers showing up to my bank to my
store or how often are my machines
breaking down
that could be an example if I have
machines that break down and they
require service from a technician those
those broken machines would be my
customers arriving to my queuing node so
a is the time in between those arrivals
s is a service time distribution
um so that would be how long it takes to
provide service at a node so if I'm
calling in to a call center and I'm on
the phone for eight minutes eight
minutes that would be my service time
and that of course is drawn from a
distribution
C would be the number of channels that
are available to us at that node so in
the previous schema we saw a b and c and
those would be the available service for
us at each queuing node
okay yeah go for it
this is the only random variable or is
it like okay
um well let me get to my next page so I
think yeah
in the time you asked the question I
prepared the next page and I think
you're gonna like it
would be like more theory yes more
Theory
good because I have more theory for you
thank you for the question and so the
simplest type of cue is that you can
work with that we're going to work with
today this is we're gonna put this into
code
is called the mm1q and what m means so
there are different like letters and you
can look this up their tables that
explain the different distributions but
what that first m means is that my
arrival process is a poisson
distribution
um that means that the time in between
the arrival of each customer how often
my machines break down and require
service or we're pulling that from an
exponential distribution
and then M would be the service time and
you can either you could make that fixed
if the amount of time it takes to do the
service is always fixed you absolutely
can but in this mm1 queuing system that
actually we're going to pull that from a
distribution to so that's also going to
be stochastic and we're going to pull
that from an exponential distribution in
general there's no
this is just like what standard to be
used for arrival times and there has
been some empirical work to line up
actual arrival times in different
complex systems and have it match up to
these distributions and so the
exponential Works quite well for a lot
of applications but of course I'm being
very general here and you may have a
specific application where you may need
to use a different distribution but then
the M1 the M the two M's are both going
to be these exponential or draws from an
exponential distribution
and the one here just means that I have
a single server
some other theory that I didn't quite
get into today that you can like if you
want more of this you can read more
about it is whether that single server
has a finite or an infinite cue in our
case we're going to when we code this up
in a moment we're going to let that
server have you know an infinite waiting
area and let as many people come into
the bank as possible
um and hopefully nobody calls the fire
department on us but we're gonna get
away with it within our code example
hopefully
what questions do we have about this
cool
all right so some of this I already said
the prior page I just wanted to clearly
lay out with the m and the m and the one
were but we have our Rivals that are
coming at a rate Lambda Lambda is just
the variable we often use to refer to a
post-on process and when you know
customers or jobs arrive to our
simulation then they're going to move
through different states in our
simulation and so that would be like
they can visit different uh servers if
we have those
um in our simulation here we just have
the what
service times we said exponential
distribution
if you need the Greek letter for it
that's going to be mu someone over mu is
going to be in service time arrival
times and service times are assumed to
be independent
I don't know does that seem like a fair
assumption to make in the real world how
many people are coming in to get service
and how long it takes my server to do
the job
and actually that's kind of a trick
question I have some people shaking
their heads no that's probably Fair
maybe if it's like a human who's doing
that service and other their other
frictions that happen you know if you
have a hundred people in your restaurant
and we can't like see people around them
then that wouldn't be there to to assume
that they're independent but maybe if
it's machines that are doing this
service then we can assume that they're
independent
all right a server serves One customer
at a time from the front of the queue so
that's going to be the first come first
served
and service is complete the customer
leaves the queue the number of customers
in the queue is going to be reduced by
one here in the mm1 queue I said the
buffer
is of infinite size so we can have as
many customers queuing up as we may
desire
within okay now we're gonna get closer
to how we talk about this in code
So within our mm1 Q simulation we're
gonna have three types of things
and the first one is the entity and the
entity refers to the thing great word
great descriptive word I know the thing
passing through the simulation so it
could be a customer a widget a car like
I said it could be a widget if it could
be an item you know I'm not a person if
it's something that requires service
like a machine that has uh that has gone
faulty and we need to fix it
every entity that passes through the
simulation is going to have attributes
attributes are just going to describe
things like the preferences or maybe
like the type of engine that has come in
for service
and the important thing to know about
those attributes is that they also have
a priority so we'll set a priority in
our code but maybe we have like VIP
customers and normal customers or maybe
in our grocery store we have people we
have a line specifically for people who
have 10 items or fewer and maybe they
get to go into a priority queue and so
we would that would be one of the
attributes of The Entity
entities are going to track their own
Journeys through the simulation so
they're going to keep track of
information about themselves as they
move through our system including the
time that they had to wait for a
resource on the processing time
so if I call the help desk I I'm
definitely going to know how long I had
to wait right and when I get to finally
have my problem fixed and I get to leave
the simulation
the resource
um The Entity is going to request
service from a resource
within the resource we have a capacity
So within the resource the capacity is
the number of entities that can receive
service simultaneously before I start
having a cue
in our example we're just going to have
capacity of one but once you take this
example and you play with it and you're
extending it you can see what happens
when you change that capacity
and then we don't just have to have a
single resource in a simulation so you
may have you know a different you may
have different resources all within the
same simulation so if you have like an
assembly line and you have some sort of
widget that breaks and first somebody
needs to like take apart the engine and
then somebody else is going to do a
diagnostic test and then somebody else
is going to replace the broken parts
those would all be different resources
within our simulation
The Source the source is sort of like
the god of our simulation the source is
what creates the entities that get to
flow through our simulation
so the source is going to know
information about like the attributes
that I should create for every entity
what priority should I give them what
preferences might they have and then the
source is going to be the one that feeds
those entities into my simulation
The Source will also be the one that
defines how frequently my entities are
showing up right if we have my customers
who are arriving to my grocery store do
they come every five minutes every 10
minutes that's going to be something
that the source knows because the source
is the one creating the entities for our
simulation
and as I said previously the M right
means that we're drawing from a
distribution from an exponential
distribution but abstractly that
inter-arrival time can be either fixed
or drawn from a simulation
more jargon more Theory time for code
hopefully it's time for code yes I
forget if there are any Pages after this
but kind of hoping it's time for code
what questions do we have on the theory
so far
simulations but mm1 is a continuous time
model
it didn't quite hear you why don't we
use So within discrete event simulation
I was saying there's cueing Theory so
there are other types of discrete event
simulation that are not queuing Theory
yeah so mm1 is a continuous time giving
model yeah I was moving why don't you
use a discrete time pre-model because
it's easier to simulate with continuous
numbers than it is to simulate with
discrete just because of like the back
end solving of the simulation
great other questions
yeah wait you didn't enjoy the theory
just for the sake of the theory you want
an output yes so
in general you would write exactly you
would be changing the parameters of your
simulation and I'm going to show you
some of the metrics that you would
measure and then you're going to be
changing the parameters of your
simulation number of servers could be
one of them and you would look at the
wait time so you would be like when Lara
calls Bank of America is it okay if she
waits for 18 minutes or should we you
know make her wait for only 10 minutes
that kind of thing yeah
I don't bank with Bank of America so
that was not like a dig on that fine
Institution
all right so we're going to be using
Senpai Senpai is the package in Python
we will use for discrete event
simulation Senpai is written in Python
python-based object oriented discrete
event simulation framework that
describes the flow of entities through a
complex system
that's really convenient because we just
talked about the theory of describing
the flow of entities through a complex
system
within Senpai we're going to see these
words again processes entities and
resources
and here I gave you some like real world
um examples of what processes entities
and resources could be and I've linked
to the source that I got these real
world examples from
um is a great medium post that you
should read if you want more information
so processes that generate entities like
customers messages computers or patients
Vehicles machines repair work in
manufacturing and then Supply demand
processes for inventory
resources would be servers counters
emergency rooms repairman Crews Tunnels
for limited capacity congestion points
so that is if you need to put things
into a real world context I don't
understand that but if you insist this
person has done the work and here are
some examples for you so
speaking of theoretical once we do our
Senpai simulation there are some you can
compare the Senpai simulation to what
would be the theoretical metrics from
our simulation are mm1 MMC if the
outputs that you get actually align with
this so this is going to be your
homework this is like the takeaway
you're going to after you run the
simulation going to take the outputs
from that simulation and calculate these
things and then you're going to send me
a message on LinkedIn telling me whether
you were able to match up the
theoretical to the simulated metrics
okay
all right and these are a couple of real
world examples so I apparently I lost
interest when I came time to find the
third one hence the empty bullet point
but I did find you two and these were
actual papers that are written
um about how to use discrete event
simulation and queuing theory in the
real world one of them is about the
number of hospital beds to have and then
I think the second link shows you a
bunch of different articles that um and
scientific journals that talk about
using this methodology
sources and suggested readings so those
links exist for you
okay ah
I don't know if you have cool places to
be in 10 minutes they told me that like
I didn't quite have to end exactly at
five and I may have internalized that so
if you have to leave at five if I'm not
gonna be offended but
let's do the code okay we're gonna write
a very simple model in simple yeah go
for it
yeah for sure
[Music]
so you can either download it from
GitHub
or you can go to the collab notebook
I don't wanna
change tabs I'll give you guys a second
all right
everybody have the URL
great
all right so a simulation has three
types of objects entities resources and
sources and we're going to Now define
those in the code
the first time that you run this you may
have to install Senpai in Senpai helpers
Senpai helpers as its name implies is a
package that makes the process of
getting statistics out of the simulation
much easier
I will say like I use this in the real
world I um knew the person who wrote it
he wrote it as like helper functions for
a course we were both taing for and I've
actually used it in my job so I recently
refactored somebody's code at work and
tried to like bring in Senpai helpers to
make that code a little bit more
understandable so I'll say I did use
that in the real world but we've got
Senpai and Senpai helpers so we're going
to import those and we're going to use
numpy to draw from distributions
and the first thing that we're going to
do is of course Define specify the
constants we're going to use in our
simulation
depending on your level of familiarity
with python right the reason that
they're in all caps is not because I am
shouting at you what the values are it's
just standard to use all caps for
constants and it's you'd normally put
them all at the very top of your
notebook or of your script so these are
numbers that you can then play with
later and see how that affects the
outputs from the simulation
the first thing that we're going to do
is to Define The Entity class the reason
that this code is working this way and
is quite simple is because of senpai
helpers
and so when I say
sorry I hate
um when people like scroll back and
forth but I forgot to tell you that from
Senpai helpers we were importing entity
resource source
and stops and so those first three we're
going to extend those
um by defining our specific classes for
this simulation so that's where entity
resource and Source come from and then
at the very end we'll use stats to get
some information back out about our
simulation
or entity class remember our entity this
is the things that are passing through
our simulation so our customers our
widgets whatever it may be
and I'm calling my class process entity
because this is going to be the code
that actually does the processing once
my entity enters the simulation so I
haven't quite yet defined the source yet
I'm defining the entity First Once the
entity arrives this is how it's going to
flow through the simulation and so
process entities what I call my class
and that's being extended from entity
which again is defined in Senpai helpers
and because we're doing that we have to
in order for the whole thing to work we
have to define a method called process
and this tells us how my entity is going
to be processed
yield you may be familiar
um and python means that we are using a
generator
and so if you're not familiar you're
going to later be Googling generators in
Python and what that means is basically
a function but a function that is stingy
and only returns to you one item at a
time so you probably have seen a
generator without even knowing it like
if you use the for Loop and you said for
I in range 5 that Range Five was
actually a generator it didn't return 0
1 2 3 4 all at once it returns zero and
then the next time it was called it
returned one Etc so that is a generator
and that is what the yield statement
means instead of a return statement so
we're going to yield self of course
that's just like the way that we can
reference our object
is going to wait for the resource and of
course my resource we're going to Define
that in the next step but first
why not do it in this order right just
to talk about the way that we're going
to process the entity first and so my
resource we will Define the resource in
a moment by the first thing we're going
to do is wait for the resource and when
we get to the res you know when we get
to the resource
what will we do
we will process at the resource when we
Define the resource we'll see that is
where we get to say how long
service is going to take at my resource
but this code is about the entity and
how the entity is going to get processed
so after I wait for the resource and
when it's finally my time I get time
with a resource I process at the
resource I'm then released from the
resource remember we said when
processing ends you leave the resource
and then you free up space for the next
entity to be
to be able to use that resource and then
of course once we get to the very end of
process and it completes running that
means once the process ends The Entity
leaves the simulation so I'll be able to
get metrics on things like the time that
it took to be served at the resource and
also the time that I spent in the
simulation from the moment that I was
incepted by the source God until I left
the simulation
okay
that is entity
are you okay with that what questions do
we have
no questions perfect
resource
resource remember is where my entities
are getting served and so what we have
to again because we are defining it we
are inheriting from the resource class
defined in Senpai helpers in order to
measures the whole process of getting
statistics easier that's why we do this
otherwise you could write these you know
you would could write these functions in
classes however you wanted and then it's
just a little bit more complex to get
the steps out but within my resource
what the minimum that we have to Define
is the service time and instead we could
Define this as fixed or stochastic and
if we're using stochastic we'll often
draw from an exponential so a good
friend numpy is going to um give us a
draw from the exponential and then the
Lambda is going to be that means service
time which as it's in all caps reminds
us that that was a constant we defined
at the beginning of the simulation
and so what is the mean service time for
this simulation
I've already forgotten so somebody has
to shout it to me
20 I heard 20. hopefully that's correct
thank you
The Source class of course is going to
be what is generating my entities here I
called it generate customers to make it
a little bit more concrete that is from
our source class and that has a minimum
two methods in it so enter arrival time
would be the time between as its name
implies between each entity arriving
that's going to be returned from an
exponential mean time between arrivals
also a constant
and then this method build entity is
going to be the method that creates all
the entities for my simulation
remember that an entity has attributes
and so here we make attributes a
dictionary
and we're going to maybe one type of
attribute is going to be the customer
type
and here within our customers we're
going to have a standard customer and a
priority customer just depending on how
much I personally like that person it
will be assigned no it's from a random
Choice from numpy standard or priority
and the reason this matters because I
remember I told you that within these
types of queuing theory models we had
the priority queue and so we Define the
priority of our entities entering the
simulation in here we say if the
customer equals a priority type and this
priority is just coming from here either
standard or priority then I set the
attribute of priority to zero setting
the attribute priority is something that
Senpai help first knows about and that's
why I can say attribute priority equals
zero
the default priority is one
and then the lower the priority number
the higher priority that entity would be
and then here we don't remember we
defined process entity in the first step
and so that we're going to be processing
our entity after we build the entity
all right we can do this we've got like
a few more minutes and now we're now
we're at running the simulation so we're
going to set a random seed uh I ran the
simulation twice once with the random
seed 34 and then with the random seed 35
today I'm 34 tomorrow I will be 35 that
is why I chose those
happy birthday thank you
so uh EMV is the standard name that
people will use for the variable that
sets up the environment that's going to
be running our simulation remember we
imported Senpai and then within Senpai
we're going to be creating an
environment that's just how you use
Senpai to run your simulation you have
to create that environment
but we create then my resource I gave it
the super
intelligible name my underscore resource
that uses the class I defined my
resource up above pass it in the
environment and then capacity and
remember that this is inheriting from
the resource class from senpai
capacity means anybody remember what
capacity means
it was one of the like 600 jargon terms
I defined for you but capacity is the
number of entities that can receive
service simultaneously before a queue
starts to form
um and it's hopefully been written here
for you in a comment
generate customers this is where we're
going to be creating the number of
entities that are running through my
simulation on the number of jobs
whatever it may be that's going to come
through my simulation so that's going to
be entities
and then kick off the simulation and V
Dot process that's just again how you
use Senpai to kick off a simulation my
source was my source that I just
defined right up here where I generated
my entities dot start and then debug is
false just because we don't want to
write out all the steps you can change
it to True yourself and see what it
prints out so that can be helpful for
debugging we're going to set it to false
here
and then env.run from the simulation
exclamation point
all right so it looked like it ran
didn't give me any errors my simulation
has completed so what the heck happened
I can use stats to get so remember stats
class comes from Senpai helpers can I
can use that to get information back
statistics on the simulation so for
example get total times would return to
me the total time every entity spent in
the simulation so here I just returned
to you the first five and these are the
first you know the total number of times
that were spent in the simulation so you
might be like what time units is this it
the time units are just in the units of
discrete numbers and so you can use
things like I'll often use Pi Arrow
um or any date time library and if I
want to do a simulation over like a
calendar amount of time
or a clock amount of time I will set my
zero point and then I can use like a
date time library to do some adjust
calculations just some arithmetic to
find out if it has been 60 units of time
I'm going to say that means that 60
seconds and then I can translate that
and I can set a starting time of like
January 1st 2020 and if it has been you
know 600 000 units of time since the
start of my simulation I could just do
arithmetic to figure out what calendar
day it is and so I haven't done that
here that's just like the next step of
complexity so if you're like how do I
turn these numbers into calendar at
times you could do something like that
but here I just want to show you the
things we can get out of stats so we can
get the total times and here I'm running
the mean on all of these so total times
waiting times and I'm processing time so
in my simulation total time 99
waiting time before you know I got to a
resource and was served and then of
course processing time so this is how
long you're on the phone with a help
desk was 33.
I can also because I set a priority I
can get the customer average waiting
time standard versus priority
okay thankfully shoot that worked I
forgot to check but thankfully priority
is a lower number and so it appears that
it did work and those customers we set
to Priority had a much lower waiting
time and then this is the processing
time on average we already saw that one
we can do things like here I've used
Seaborn just to do some plotting so this
is a histogram for time and simulation
and this is the count of the entities
believe we ran 200 entities through and
so looks like most of them
oh
sorry it's five o'clock
um this is a Instagram of the number of
entities that waited this amount of time
units
we've got the waiting time per entity so
this was the waiting times this is the
cue size over time
and then
the not the only thing that's left I
re-ran it using a different random seed
and then you can just like compare the
outputs to see that they've changed and
of course you can go through and change
the constants for a simulation change
the capacity and see how the simulation
would run
so
that is what I've got for you on
simulation in Python using senpai
I look I'm happy to stick around if you
have questions but I won't hold
everybody else up so thank you so much
[Applause]